The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Let me do
a little bit of where we've been
and where we're going,
a little wayfinding.
We did the last two--
the last two sessions were on
individuals and households.
We did a rational actor
model, a little drive demand,
maximized preferences.
And then we talked about
preferences being learned.
We talked about preferences
depending on others.
And particularly in
the last session,
we talked about economic
style, if you will.
Maximization is only
one form of cognition.
That sometimes we all
behave automatically
rather than thoughtfully.
I have a very large book to
read over spring vacation
by Kahneman called Thinking
Fast and Thinking Slow that's
all about this--
good stuff.
And Max Weber's distinction
between rational pursuit
of ends, rational pursuit
of an ideal or value.
It feels good or we
just do it out of habit.
So we went from sort
of a rational actor
story about individuals
and households
to more complicated
view of behavior.
We're going to do the
same thing with firms.
So today is about a
rational actor model
about maximizing
something-- we'll
talk at the outset about what.
And then we'll talk about
behavioral complications.
Whatever it is we think
firms ought to maximize
as demanders-- mainly of
energy, that's the focus--
before the break.
They don't necessarily
maximize anything.
First, they're full of people.
And people don't necessarily
maximize anything.
And there's an additional
layer of complication,
which is what we'll
spend most of our time
on, because people
in organizations
are more complicated than
people individually because
of the structures, and
incentives, and relationships,
and so forth.
After vacation, we'll
spend a little bit--
and these are normative
prescriptive sessions--
on supply-side
strategy, how might one
do an energy business.
So that's where we're going.
It's worth spending
some time, though, on--
is this reasonably clear?
Are the questions?
Let me-- before I pass on--
OK.
If households maximize utility,
what should firms maximize?
If it's your own firm--
my dad ran a garage.
My dad could do whatever he
wanted-- maximize utility,
maximize profit--
who cares?
There's nobody to
tell him what to do.
He aimed for profit, actually.
But for corporations,
it's different
because modern corporations
have diffuse ownership, right?
The Exxon executives maybe own
a reasonable fraction of Exxon,
but that reasonable
fraction might be 10%.
Some other companies,
it's higher--
some younger
companies, it's higher.
But in a lot of companies, the
executives are not the owners.
And the question is, what
should the executives maximize--
if they should
maximize anything?
Milton Friedman
was writing, when
there were debates about
imposing wage and price
controls to deal
with what seemed then
like a lot of inflation--
we had much more later years,
but it seemed like a lot
of inflation in '70, '71, when,
in '71, when Nixon did impose
price controls--
which mostly failed.
And Milton Friedman has
a distinct point of view
about what corporate executives
should be told to maximize.
Anybody?
Columbus, what do you say?
What does Milton Friedman say
should be the instruction?
AUDIENCE: Profits.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Profit.
OK.
Why not do some social good?
What's the argument against
saying to Exxon, oh, come on,
you're a big, rich company.
Do some good.
AUDIENCE: Well, there's
a few different reasons
why, for the stockholders,
they might not
want to do that
for the [INAUDIBLE]
if they do that, they're not
spending their own money.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well,
that's disappointing.
You gave a complete answer.
Now who am I going
to call on next?
Does anybody want
to supplement that?
I mean, that's the basic answer.
It's taxation without
representation.
If the owners want to spend
money on charity, fine.
But-- and if they want to tell
the executive to do that, fine.
But if they don't, why should
the executives of Exxon
do social good?
So Friedman says, nope.
Their business is to make money.
The owners can
contribute to charity.
We'll start the
debate in a minute,
but let's clarify
his point of view.
Did you want to add to that?
AUDIENCE: I just wanted to add
that corporations can get tax
deductions for
donating to charities,
so it's kind of a way to
pay money to get [INAUDIBLE]
charitable, but really,
you're just trying to--
I mean, you're just paying your
taxes in a different direction.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So you're saying
that a firm can do things
that might not necessarily
look to be profit maximization,
like giving to charity,
but might be thought
through correctly
contribute to their
long-run success.
So you wouldn't necessarily want
to squeeze every nickel out.
OK.
So Friedman would
let you do that.
But Friedman would say, how
do you choose what charity?
Who chooses?
The CEO's favorite charity.
Maybe that's part of
his or her compensation.
Anybody else on Friedman.
OK.
What's handy-- Yeah,
go ahead, Maxwell.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I was just going to say
[INAUDIBLE] and then you have
[INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
It becomes a political entity,
except that there's no voting.
That it's making
collective decisions
like a taxing authority.
But it's basically taking money
out of the owners' pockets.
David?
AUDIENCE: So
basically, they just
don't have any right to
choose where to donate to.
And they don't have
that [INAUDIBLE]
select CEOs that are good
at policy [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Murray
does make an interesting point,
which is that if I give it to
you in the form of dividends,
it gets taxed at
the corporate level
as well as at the
personal level.
Yeah, you can get a tax
deduction personally,
but you get that
corporate tax hit.
So it's a little more efficient
if the corporation contributes.
But who's to let them
decide what to contribute.
OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Also, a corporation's
main responsibility
is just to make a profit for
itself and for shareholders.
And so some corporations have
it in their mission statement
that they do good will and
good work, and stuff like that.
And so then I think it's more
acceptable to have charity
be part of the company because
it's part of their mission
statement.
But the majority of
corporations, their mission
is to make a profit for
the shareholders, so.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, they would usually
have a mission statement that's
a little more exalted than that
if they have a
mission statement--
unless they're explicitly
charitable, and some are,
right?
There are these corporations--
which are very interesting--
that treat profits
as a constraint, not an
objective that are charitable.
Well, Newman's salad
dressing, for instance.
They maximize profits
to give to charity.
There are companies-- what's the
term-- social enterprises that
basically say, we're going
to make just enough money
to survive.
And we're going to do good
in the following ways.
You can think about a
number of things like that.
What's Handy say?
Handy disagrees.
Handy's writing-- let me
just see if we've got--
I think we've got
the main points.
Yup.
Handy's writing after
the dotcom bust.
OK, Friedman's
writing in a landscape
where an issue of the day
is, should the government
step in and control prices?
Handy's writing after the
dotcom bust when stocks went up,
stocks came down like a stone,
lots of companies went broke.
What's Handy say the
firms should be about?
Benzi, you're writing down,
and I'm not saying anything.
So you must be preparing
your answer to this question.
So what does Handy
say that the firm
should the firm should be about?
AUDIENCE: I didn't get
a chance to read it.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK.
OK.
Thank you for your honesty.
Matthew?
AUDIENCE: I have
the same [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: You
have to same-- somebody
must have read it.
I'm sure there's somebody
in this group that
read the Handy paper--
doesn't summarize easily.
Veronica?
Fire away.
AUDIENCE: It wasn't on Stellar.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Was
it really not on Stellar?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It was only preview.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: I got it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: This morning--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: No, I
printed it out last week.
It wasn't up?
Was it marked staff only?
Did we screw it up and
mark it staff only?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: No, no.
It was posted.
It was posted months ago.
The only thing I can think of as
it may have been inadvertently
labeled staff only.
Well, in which case,
because I pulled it off to--
I mean, here it is,
exactly from Stellar.
So I'll tell you what Handy
says and we can talk about it.
Handy's a funny article, right?
He's writing in the--
so you could have just
said, you couldn't get it.
And then you would
have been good.
It's a lot of criticism of
the short-term focus in stock
options and all of that.
He says profits are
a means not an end.
It's a completely
different vision.
That a good firm is, "a
community with a purpose."
That's his phrase.
And you should treat
employees like--
as stakeholders.
He's one of the coiners of the
stakeholder view of the firm.
That a firm doesn't exist
to serve just its owners,
it exists to serve the
communities it operates in.
It exists to serve its employees
who've invested at least some--
made some investments
of time and energy
that will be lost if they leave
the firm or if the firm fails.
So he would say, a good
firm is about something,
not just about making
money to shareholders.
And a good firm will go beyond
minimal legal requirements
for something like things
like environment, and safety,
and so forth.
So you have two very
different views.
You have a classical
economic view from Friedman.
You've been employed
by the owners,
you have a fiduciary
responsibility for the owners.
Don't spend the owners'
money without authorization
or instruction.
And the Handy view that
says, that's too simple.
Lots of other people have
a stake in the firm--
the community, the employees,
the environment, et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera.
So you really need
to take a broader
view of what you're about.
Now that you've had a complete
clear exposition of what
I must say is a little
bit of a murky article,
we'll make sure you can
get it this afternoon.
What do you think?
Where do you come down?
Sam?
Handy's view is a little
more humane, isn't it?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Also, like, we have
the kind of a [INAUDIBLE]
their employees
will be more happy.
And that would just make
it a better place to work,
which will in turn be--
make the firm more productive.
Where if you're
trying to just like
have like a ruthless,
cost-cutting machine type
thing, it's going to be a
miserable place to work.
And it's not going to be just
a flourishing environment.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, Friedman says,
OK, I'll take that.
I love that.
We will be about
something because that'll
motivate people--
that's profit maximization.
You've just given me
profit maximization.
I've given you--
a great example--
I'll mention two firms that
I served on the boards of.
The one was a startup,
became the International
Securities Exchange.
It was the first
all-electronic Options Exchange
in the country.
And everybody made
money, but the mission--
not quite chiseled in
stone, but the mission
that everybody talked
about was, we're
going to upset this market.
Trading is slow, commissions
are ridiculously high,
we could offer a much
better product to the world.
Well, you can go
to work-- you can
get up and go to work for that.
The other is the International
Data Group, which
has a clear mission statement.
It's to provide information
about information technology
so that technology
can have more impact.
Well, you can kind of go
to work for that, too.
The notion that we exist to
make money for our owners
a little hard to get up
and get excited about.
So Friedman said-- Friedman
will come along with you
and say, yes.
And there's a nice example.
Handy mentions Merck.
Beginning in 1988, they
had invented this drug
that cures river
blindness, which
is a very nasty disease that
infects people in Africa.
I mean, young people go blind
from swimming, basically,
but getting in the water.
And the stuff is reasonably
expensive to make.
They couldn't actually
sell it into Africa.
So they give it away.
They give it away.
It's free.
They make it available free.
And you say, how can that
be profit maximizing?
Well, if you walk into
the Merck headquarters,
there's a large statue
of a young boy with--
as I remember it-- somebody
in a white coat with his hand
on the boy's shoulder.
And you say to anybody at
Merck, what's that about?
They tell you this story.
Well, you can get
up and go to work
for a company that
says, yeah, we're
about more than making money.
We saw something that we could
uniquely do for the world
and we did it.
We're not just
about making money.
So Friedman--
Friedman loves this.
Anything-- would you go further?
Julien.
We've got your name corrected.
That's fabulous.
Good.
AUDIENCE: Well, I mean, I
would disagree with Friedman
because he may be
right in some cases
that perhaps some companies
would find it in their best
interest to do social good.
However, let's say-- let's
take a look at McDonald's.
I'm sure their workers aren't
happy about their wages.
And I'm pretty sure McDonald's
could pay them a bit more
But I mean, that might
be seen as a social good
to earn more than minimum
wage for your workers--
or pay more than
minimum wage-- and I'm
sure McDonald's could
probably afford it.
But seeing as they generally
don't pay that much,
it's not really in their
interest for social good.
So it's generally about
profit, I would say.
And so Friedman, I would say,
is incorrect in that firms
don't always do like
social good for profit.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Sometimes they
do social good for social good.
By the way, I think it's
the local franchisee who
makes the wage decisions,
and whether that person can
afford it or not depends.
AUDIENCE: OK,
different example then.
Let's say coal mines
back in the day--
or like during
industrialization,
clothing factories.
Like weren't
people-- the labor--
they were people in
horrible conditions
and paid them horrible wages--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
But remember, we're
talking prescription,
not description.
Friedman says, that's OK.
Handy says, that's not OK.
What do you say?
You say it's not OK.
Or do you say it's OK?
What would you tell
the executives to do?
AUDIENCE: Better
working conditions.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK.
Do coal mines ever fail?
Go out of business, go broke?
Yeah.
Even with those lousy
working conditions.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
not necessarily
an effect of the working
conditions [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: No, no.
It's not.
But if you raise costs,
you raise the probability.
So here's another
Merck example from--
that needs a paren--
from 1999 to 2004,
close paren, Merck
had information about
the adverse health
effects of a popular drug
prescribed for arthritis.
A friend of mine
took it regularly.
And it had very--
it had bad side
effects they had
information on the bad side
effects-- they hid it.
They hid the information.
And during that period,
they sold a lot of Vioxx
and made a lot of money.
Was that profit maximizing?
Handy would oppose it.
Would Friedman oppose it?
Charlotte?
AUDIENCE: But isn't
that one illegal?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well, yes.
There is that.
AUDIENCE: But are we talking
about things that are illegal?
Or are we just
talking about things
that could be or couldn't be,
like depending on the decision
by the owners, like
the legality of it.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: I actually
don't know if it was illegal.
They certainly were sued.
I'm not sure of the legality.
Suppose it was legal.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] to meet
their legal requirements.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Suppose it was legal.
Bad law.
The law didn't actually say,
you got to disclose bad effects.
The law was badly written, and
it let them get away with it.
Then, should they have--
AUDIENCE: I think they would
both disagree with that
because personally, if I
were working for a firm that
was hiding the adverse effects
of a drug that someone I knew
might be taking, that wouldn't
be a reason for me to go
to work every day.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
That would be hard.
Rachel?
AUDIENCE: I feel like
for in both cases,
it just kind of depends
for individual companies
how much they value-- or how
much consumer opinion of them
matters to their business.
I mean, this case,
like it might not
be profit maximizing
if it's really, really
important that the public
have a good view of them
in the first case.
It might be that the amount
of money that they're
losing by giving
away the drug is
overcome by the amount of
goodwill they're earning.
So it just kind of
depends on the firm.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Actually,
one thing that's-- it'd be
interesting to know there, and
I don't know the details, is,
at what level of the firm was
the decision made to conceal?
It could be the person
whose bonus depended
on sales as opposed to the CEO.
Samantha?
AUDIENCE: I was
just going to I say
that I think I'm more on
the Handy side of things,
that firms have an obligation--
a moral obligation,
as well as an obligation
to maximize profit.
And something like hiding
adverse of effects of a drug
is, in my opinion,
morally wrong.
And it's not something
that a firm--
I mean, I would
think that Friedman
would be OK with something
like that, and Handy would not.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
companies do balance like PR
and public opinion
with them with profit
maximizing because
public opinion of them
affects the profits.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: And it's
nice to have a mission when
you can have a mission,
but Wednesday, we're
going to talk about a
firm in upstate New York
that makes formaldehyde.
And I just don't know how--
it may be technically
interesting to run the firm,
to run the plant,
but I don't see
how you get socially
charged by that one.
Just one last,
and than I do want
to get on to capitol budgeting.
And let's just
think about this one
because think about
how much of an issue
Romney's venture
capital experience--
actually, a private
equity experience--
has been in this campaign,
where they closed plants,
they closed firms.
And it's portrayed as
the wrong thing to do.
Sometimes there's no choice.
Sometimes there is a choice.
Is there a moral
issue involved here?
Is there not a moral issue.
I'm a McDonald's
franchisee, just
to go to Julien's favorite
dining establishment.
And I've got six stores--
and I'm losing money
on one of them.
Do I have a moral
obligation to keep
it open because of the
people or can I shut it down?
Or suppose, in fact, I'm
not losing money on it.
It's reasonably profitable.
But I get a really good
offer from somebody who
wants to make it a parking lot.
And I can take that money,
open another restaurant
in a better location
across town,
where, yeah, I could
employ those people,
but they won't be
able to get there.
So I'll take it.
You had a reaction?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I mean, there could
be another company
that could come in and do more
good to the community than just
another parking lot.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Parking lot-- maybe.
Maybe.
Maybe the community is
desperate for parking.
Let me go to capital
budgeting because I think this
will take us a little while.
We're about firms for the
next several sessions.
And the diagram-- my favorite
diagram that we started with--
firms supply energy,
supply energy services,
firms use energy-- that's where
going to focus for a while.
Firms supply products
that use energy,
and firms supply products
that help supply energy.
In all of these cases, the
firms make decisions involving
costs and benefits phased out--
spread out over many
years with uncertainty.
I'm going to assume
some version of Friedman
because I don't know how to
model Handy, other than as,
you have to think carefully
about the long term.
And if I have a
moral obligation,
I'll add that on top of this.
So the basic story is we're
going to maximize value.
That's not maximizing
today's share price.
There's a nice phrase in
Brealey, Myers, and Allen
that talks about the
honest share price.
They don't mean, by that,
in the absence of fraud.
They mean in the presence
of very good information.
So you want to maximize how
much the firm is worth--
if everybody knows as
much as you do and indeed
knows that much
about other firms.
So in the case of
Merck you'd want
to assume they know about Vioxx.
If I could go to the capital
markets, and I can invest,
and I can borrow, and
I can raise stock,
and it's a simple world--
isn't that a lovely picture--
the rule to do this
is straightforward.
Again, we're going to
talk about investments--
not operating decisions,
but investment decisions.
You make all
investments that have
a positive net present value.
This is net present value in
discrete, not continuous terms.
And we do this because
continuous compounding doesn't
simplify, particularly,
when you've
got flows that vary over time.
It's nice in very simple cases.
I love the elegance,
but if you want
to work out the net present
value of something like this--
this is an oil lease,
hypothetically.
So CAPEX-- Capital
Expenditures--
are incurred early on,
oil production ramps,
levels declines.
And to value this
opportunity, you've
got to figure, what am I
going to get from selling oil?
What are the
Operating Expenses--
OPEX-- associated with
getting that oil out?
What are the royalties
I'm going to owe?
And what are the taxes
I'm going to have to pay?
I take the net
and I discount it.
And the opportunity
cost of capital--
we'll spend quite a while on--
is what I could make
on an investment
of comparable riskiness.
What's that mean?
I'll come back to it.
But if I can do better investing
in this oil lease, then
anything else that's handy
that's of comparable riskiness,
I should make this investment.
If I can make--
we'll see next time, the
calculations for Wednesday
have to do with an investment
in energy conservation.
So it's the same thing.
I can invest in lots
of things, but if I
can invest in
energy conservation,
and it gives me a better
return than an investment
of comparable riskiness,
I ought to do it.
Now that's a pretty
simple formula, right?
You just did
something that the--
cash flows that occur in
period J, take a discount rate,
discount it back to the
present at interest rate R,
and you do this
on a spreadsheet.
And you'll see a
spreadsheet Wednesday.
So a couple simple basics here.
The first is cash matters.
Profits don't matter, except
insofar as they affect taxes.
So this is-- when
you do present value
for a firm, the question is,
what are my actual returns,
not what does the accountant
put on the bottom of the paper?
And the main example
is depreciation.
Depreciation is
not a cash expense.
It affects your taxes.
And you'll see for Wednesday,
you have to consider that.
But it doesn't directly
impact the cash in the bank.
It's something the
accountant writes down.
So you use cash flows--
relentlessly focus
on cash flows.
There are a couple
of simple formulas.
That's the formula for
a perpetuity, something
that starts with a constant
payment one year out,
goes forever.
You'll see it's
the same formulas
for continuous compounding, but
obviously, the interest rate's
different.
This is compounded
once a period.
And this is nice in
Brealey, Myers, and Allen.
Suppose you have a bond that
pays c per year for capital T
years, what's it worth?
Well, if the interest
rate's R, that's
equivalent to a perpetuity
starting today--
starting in one year--
minus a perpetuity
starting in year T plus 1.
I subtract that and I get
this simple little formula
on the right.
I could also do a T period power
series, but that's cleaner.
This is the formula you'd use--
that's the formula
for a mortgage,
except you use a
monthly interest rate.
So if you know what the
value of the mortgage
is and you know the
yield on the mortgage, R,
you can solve for
the monthly payment.
That's a standard bond
or mortgage formula.
The last point I want to
make on this slide is--
is all this clear?
Questions, or
comments, or reactions?
OK.
Suppose prices are going
up at 10% and the bank is--
at 10% a year--
and the bank is
paying 5% a year.
You're not making money on the
investment in the bank, right?
You're losing purchasing power.
The real interest rate,
whatever it is, is negative.
You put $100 in the bank
today, a year from now,
you get something that's worth
less because of inflation
than that $100.
Even though it's $105,
inflation's gone up.
Well, to figure out the
relation between the market
or nominal interest rate,
capital R, the inflation rate
I and the real interest rate,
it's pretty straightforward.
I put the money in the
bank at 5%, I get $1.05.
I basically got
to knock that down
by the amount of
inflation that's occurred.
And this gives me the
increase in purchasing power.
So another way to think about
it-- or another example,
suppose the bank's paying
5%, inflation is 5%.
I get $105, which
is worth exactly,
in terms of what I can
buy, what $100 was today.
So the interest rate--
the real interest
rate, the increase in the
purchasing power is zero.
If those two are equal, this
is zero, and that makes sense.
Inflation has wiped
out the earnings.
If you just multiply
this through,
you get this relationship.
Normally, the product of these
two rates, I and little r,
is negligible.
Although, I'm told in periods
of high inflation in Israel,
people actually do
carry this second term.
It's normally very small.
And you get the result
that the real interest
rate, in any sane circumstance,
is the market interest
rate minus the inflation rate.
OK.
And that's the relationship
every everybody uses.
It's important to understand
which interest rates
you're using,
whether you're using
a real rate or a nominal rate.
But are we OK on this?
Everybody nods,
everybody's happy.
Almost all interest
rates are nominal, right?
You look up interest
rates in the newspaper,
they are, here's what
we'll pay you in a year.
They don't depend on
the rate of inflation.
All else equal,
of course, they're
going to be higher the higher
inflation is expected to be.
We had breathtaking
interest rates
in the late '70s, early '80s
when inflation was running.
We had mortgage rates of
18%, for heaven's sake.
If you expect high
inflation, you're
going to want to get
more dollars back.
Now you can look at real
interest rates in the past,
of course.
You can look at
what was the rate--
what was the
one-year bond rate--
on a one-year bond rate,
government bond rate,
let's say, on January 1, 1956.
What was the inflation
between January of 1956
and January of 1957?
I can subtract and get
the real interest rate.
What do I do going forward?
Going forward, it's
a little trickier.
There is a bond sold by the
Treasury-- you can buy them--
called TIPS, Treasury
Information Protected
Securities.
They adjust so they pay
you in real dollars.
So the interest rate is a real
interest-- interest rate quoted
is a real interest rate.
So last Friday-- when I was
able to download Handy--
last Friday, I checked
the 20-year rate
on regular government bonds.
That was 2.83% from
the Treasury's website.
And the rate on 10-year
TIPS was a half a percent.
These are breathtaking
numbers, historically.
It's a half a percent.
So I'd say the market in
some sense has an inflation
expectation over 10
years of just a little
over 2%, which is sort
of a reasonable number,
historically.
But it's a bit of a
thin market, and TIPS
have special characteristics,
and not everybody buys them.
So I wouldn't say you can always
look up the market's inflation
expectations this way.
But it gives you a sense.
It gives you a sense.
Not a sharp tool, but a tool.
The biggest mistake
people make in doing
present value in
almost any setting
is to confuse which
interest rate they're using.
Are you using a real
rate or a nominal rate?
Now the normal thing you do when
you're doing a present value
calculation, and it involves
so many pounds of cement
per year over 10 years,
you use today's pound of--
today's price for cement.
That's the normal thing to do.
Today's price for steel,
today's price for whatever,
figure out physical
quantities, and get cash flows.
If you do that, you need
to use a real discount
rate because you've
assumed zero inflation
by using today's prices.
If you use a nominal
rate from the market,
then you need to adjust--
then you need to
say, well, the rates
I use are 5%, 10%, whatever they
are, but I expect 2% inflation.
So I'll build in 2% inflation.
I mean, you could do
it either way, right?
You can use today's prices,
take 2% off the market.
But what you can't do is mix.
You can't take a rate from the
capital market like that 2.83
up there, and then
assume price is constant
because that 2.83 is based
on people's expectation
that prices will rise--
that prices will rise.
So it's a very common mistake.
Just don't do it.
And know to look for it
when people show you,
as they will in later life,
present values because it's
common, it's easy to make.
And it can certainly
get you the wrong answer
if there's any
inflation going on
or the time period is
of any length at all.
OK.
That's issue one,
get the rates right.
The rates matter.
Well, let's do this one first.
The question is, where
does that R come from?
And I said it's an
opportunity cost of capital.
It's what you can
get on an investment
of comparable riskiness.
Well, if there's no risk--
even though the US
government was downrated--
it's normal to treat a
riskless rate as the government
borrowing rate.
There's essentially
no risk of repayment
unless you're a real pessimist.
And again, you'd use the
US rate, not necessarily
the Greek rate these
days after the write-off.
But suppose there is some risk.
Well, as I say, it's
an opportunity cost.
So that says you would expect--
if you're going
to bear more risk,
your expectation of a return
has to be higher to compensate.
So you would expect
a higher risk
means a higher discount rate.
That sort of makes sense.
So-- that's cute--
so you normally discount
the expected cash flows
at a risk-adjusted
discount rate--
I'm going to come to,
what do I mean by risk?
Because that's the
$64,000 question here.
But so far, I assume
this is fairly intuitive.
And if a project has some
things that are certain
and some things
that are uncertain,
you might want to use
different discount rates.
If part of the cash flows are
returns on government bonds,
those are riskless and
I ought to discount them
using the government bond rate.
Part of it is sales of Teslas,
I might use a higher discount
rate for sales of
Teslas, or Chevy Volts ,
or tickets to John Carter,
or almost anything else.
I'd use a use a higher rate.
But what do I mean by that?
How do I think about risk?
OK, two points to make.
One, it matters.
This is not particularly
on point, but I like it.
It illustrates the importance
of discount rate choices
you go out in time.
This equivalent
cash-flow haircut says,
OK, a dollar in one year
at 7% is worth $0.71.
At 10%, it's worth $0.62.
That's equivalent to
taking 13% off, right?
Raising the discount
rate from 7% to 10%
is equivalent to a 13% haircut
on what you're going to get.
And 30 years out,
it's a huge haircut.
30 years out it, more
than cuts it in half.
So the discount rate matters.
The choice-- again,
a nice picture--
is you've got project A, Project
B. Project B looks very safe,
project A looks very
risky, but has a higher--
let's take that to be
the expected value.
The distribution's
a little asymmetric.
Which do you choose?
How do you think about risk?
Well, it turns out
the right answer
isn't variance or anything
quite like variance.
I'm going to walk you
through a bit of finance
much too quickly.
So listen for the concepts,
don't listen for the details.
I just want you to get the basic
notion here, not the mechanics.
We're not going to
do the mechanics.
The mechanics will
not be on the quiz.
But the concept is important.
Jessica?
AUDIENCE: Which would
you say is safer?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: Which one of these
two would you say is safer?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: B is safer.
Sure.
Much less spread in
the possible outcomes.
A's got huge spreads in
And we don't even know where
the zero point is on that graph.
So just looking at it,
you'd say A is safer.
That says, well, a
nice measure might
be the dispersion, the
variance, the range, whatever--
not quite.
So here's the basic story.
I can't believe I set this
to fly in, I hate that.
It's distracting.
It's easy to show that investors
should always diversify.
If you read anything
about investment--
you can make it mathematical,
but if you read anything
about investment, it says
you should diversify.
OK.
This was made very fancy in
the '50s by Harry Markowitz.
Second step, was Tobin--
Jim Tobin-- James
Tobin-- let's be fair--
in the '60s, who said,
well, if you have really
well-functioning capital
markets that every investor
should hold some of all
risky securities and then
some safe security.
So let's suppose I've got
a bunch of risky stocks,
let's say, and US
government debt.
Then everybody's portfolio
should be composed
of some of all the stocks--
that is, to say the
market portfolio--
and then some government debt.
And how much of each
you hold would depend
on your tolerance for risk.
All right.
So that says you want to think
about-- again, everybody's
efficient, everybody's
optimizing,
nobody listens to my broker,
everybody's very efficient
and holds the market
portfolio, right?
Some shares of each one.
Now you can sort of do that,
index funds come close.
But of course, in theory,
the market portfolio
isn't just the stock market.
It also would include real
estate, and gold, and anything
else you think of
as an asset you
might hold in your portfolio.
But if you think about
rational investors holding
diversified portfolios, and
the risky part of the portfolio
having the same
composition for everybody,
then you would expect--
again, if you're dividing your
holdings between government
securities that are riskless,
and a bunch of stocks
and whatever else
that's risky, the more
you tilt toward that
risky portfolio,
you better get a
higher expected return.
You better have a higher
average expected return
to compensate for
bearing the risk.
So this was Sharpe--
and we'll jump to his answer.
That's just a general
statement of the expectation--
that the market portfolio,
all the risky stuff,
should yield a better
return in expectation--
not every day, as we know.
But in expectation, it better
do better than government debt
or why would you ever hold it?
It's risky?
So you would expect there
to be a risk premium.
What this goes to, if you
think about this world in which
people are holding mixtures of
government securities and lots
of risky stuff, then
comes another asset.
Is it risky or not?
How do I think about its risk?
Well, I think about its
risk in terms of what
it does to my portfolio.
I don't care what
it does by itself.
I'm holding all
these other assets
because I'm a rational
diversified investor.
So what matters
to me if I'm going
to buy it is, what difference
does it make to my portfolio
before and after?
That's not just a
question of variance.
That's a question
of correlation.
And the example here is a stock
that moves against everything
else, even if it moves a lot,
can be a great thing to own.
Because if I own some
of this and something
that moves in the
opposite direction,
I can construct a
risk-free security.
That's pretty good.
So it doesn't matter that--
in this view of the
world, what matters
is how the returns on an
asset, returns on a security,
relate to the returns
on everything else.
Basically, that
two-fund theorem says,
you're going to hold
something of everything else.
That's going to be the risky
part of your portfolio.
That's going to move.
And if I pick up
another risky asset,
what matters is, how does
that affect the movement
of that whole bundle?
Which says that the
picture I had before--
this one-- asks
the wrong question.
That just tells me maybe
something about variance.
It doesn't tell me
anything about correlation.
If the world consists
of Apple stock--
blast-- if the world consists
of US government debt and Apple
stock, then the question of
whether an oil well is risky
or not is, does it
move with Apple stock?
Does it move
against Apple stock?
If it moves against Apple
stock, I can reduce my risk.
If it moves with
Apple stock, I'll
increase it by adding
it to my portfolio.
So that's the sort
of key insight that--
now I made a lot-- there are
a lot of assumptions floating
around here, and I'm
going to relax them orally
in a little bit.
I can't relax them
mathematically and get done.
But the assumption
here is we're dealing
with a world in which there are
very few transactions costs,
investors are
behaving rationally,
everything is smooth, it's
a very competitive world--
in the financial market.
That's probably wrong.
But it's not clear where you
would go from there to a better
model.
So let me not defend
this model as truth,
let me just defend
this model is the best
one we have at the moment.
And it says to a
reasonable approximation,
smart people diversify.
When smart people diversify,
what matters isn't just,
does it move, but what
does it move with?
So the Sharpe model
has this implication--
oh, sorry.
I need to go back
to that last point.
This is a very interesting point
that comes out of this model.
It says not only do I care--
if the world is a risk-less
asset and Apple stock,
comes another investment that
has uncertain returns, if it
moves with Apple stock, getting
it would increase my risk.
If it moves against
Apple stock, getting it
would decrease my risk.
What if it's uncorrelated?
What if it's uncorrelated
with the other risk
in the economy-- in that
case, with the market?
Well, if it's uncorrelated
and it's on the market,
everybody holds a
little bit of it,
it doesn't affect the movement
of your portfolio much.
I'm just going to
have to let you--
you're going to have to
take that one on faith.
But risk uncorrelated with the
market can be diversified away.
It doesn't justify
a risk premium
in this world, where what
matters is the portfolio.
Holding it by itself
would be risky.
Holding a little piece
of it, uncorrelated
with anything else, turns
out to have effectively
zero impact on portfolio risk.
So we talk about risk
that's uncorrelated
with the market
as diversifiable.
And it doesn't demand
a risk premium--
in this world.
I'll give you a little bit
about another world in a minute.
But in this world, it doesn't
demand a risk premium.
So we're flying along--
concepts, concepts,
portfolio is what matters,
correlations matter.
This is Sharpe's
model that, again,
under reasonable
assumptions widely used,
if something has a zero--
it turns out the measure
of risk now is beta.
The whole market has a
beta of 1 by definition,
risk-free rate has a beta of
zero because it doesn't move,
it has no risk.
Things that move
against the market
have negative betas, things
that move toward the market--
with the market depending on the
correlation and the movement,
will have a positive beta.
Beta is the measure
of covariance
is not quite right-- of
covariance with the market.
And higher beta securities have
a higher required or expected
return, higher beta assets.
So an example-- this is
the cost of equity for BP.
It's an estimate.
Basically, by definition,
it got identically equal.
By definition, the beta on
the market as a whole is 1.
It turns out that BP
and other major oil
producers are less risky in this
regard than the average stock.
Beta is 0.8 for BP.
You can estimate
it, and here would
be an example of calculating the
required-- or the opportunity
cost for investments that
look like BP's investments.
So we look at what the
market requires from BP.
Well, we know it's beta.
We can estimate that--
no point going into it here.
Suppose the risk
free rate is 3%.
The market as a whole has
a risk premium of 5.4%--
that, again, you can calculate--
that gives a cost of equity
for BP--
opportunity cost-- of 7.3%.
That's what investors would
take to own BP stock in terms
of expected return
or another investment
of comparable riskiness.
Comparable riskiness-- beta 0.8.
So the measure of riskiness
becomes a simple number, beta.
Now that's-- again,
it's a simple model.
I'm not expecting you to
understand anything other
than that beta
involves not variance,
but covariance and
correlation-- it involves
comovements with other assets.
As I say, this is
the opportunity cost
of investing in
projects is risky as BP.
So if you-- are
we semi-OK so far?
The concept here.
We're in a world where
everybody diversifies,
everybody diversifies
as much as they can.
It turns out the
rational way to do
that is for everybody to
hold the same proportion
of risky assets.
So if you have two shares of
Apple and one share of GM,
I might have four shares of
Apple and two shares of GM.
But I don't reverse
the proportions
because we're both owning
pieces of the market
in the same percentage.
And in that world,
what matters is
how things correlate
with the market
and also how big the moves are.
And beta captures both of those.
As that earlier slide says, it
captures both the correlation
and the volatility.
It captures the correlation
and the standard deviation
of its own movements.
So if we're going
to do discounting,
figure out what the
cash flows are, probably
use the expected cash flows.
We might want to be
conservative and use
the lower bounds of revenues
and upper bounds of costs,
or be optimistic.
Figure out how
risky the thing is--
and frankly, this is very--
it's very easy
for common stocks.
It's a little harder for
an investment project.
If I say, well, I think this
project has a beta of 0.8,
how do I get there?
You could see that the key
thing that people usually
do-- so this is the split
of a particular project.
The first thing you ask is, is
the risk diversifiable or not?
Is it correlated to
a first approximation
with movements in the rest
of the economy or not?
So there's some uncertainty.
We're going to put in--
let's say it's a wind farm.
We're going to
build a wind farm.
There is some
uncertainty-- we've
got the we've got the
equipment under contract.
There's uncertainty
about how difficult it's
going to be to put the thing in
place, to do the installation,
to do the construction.
That's not going
to be correlated
with the rest of the economy.
That's just local.
That's a local risk.
That's diversifiable.
If I can get enough
people to hold that risk,
it's not going to matter
to anybody because it's not
going to move their portfolio.
The wages I have to
pay will be correlated
with the rest of the economy.
So if I haven't
fixed wages and I
haven't fixed prices for
materials, then maybe that does
need to be discounted
because it is correlated.
Again, it's diversifiable
versus nondiversifiable.
Is it correlated
with the market,
with the rest of the economy?
Or is it just something random
that's going to happen to me?
I don't know the wind
conditions very well,
or the reservoir conditions, or
a variety of things like that.
Is that going to be correlated
with the rest of the economy?
Probably not.
That's probably
diversifiable risk,
and I shouldn't
worry about the beta
because it's probably zero.
It's not correlated
with other things.
Oh, how much am I going to get
out in terms of kilowatt hours?
The wind is uncertain.
I don't know what my
annual production is
going to be from the wind farm.
That's probably diversifiable.
That is to say it, whether
the wind blows or doesn't blow
isn't going to be correlated
with the rest of the economy,
probably.
Unless I have a
long-term contract,
the price at which I
sell power will for sure
be correlated with
everything else.
That's not diversifiable, right?
The market moves up,
the economy moves up,
the wholesale price of
electricity goes up.
So that's going to have
a significant beta.
This other stuff,
not so much, so I'm
not going to worry too
much about the risk.
So I would treat
the two differently.
OK so far?
Now-- let's do
slightly different.
There are different degrees
when you're doing this exercise.
We will see a cost-saving
project on Wednesday.
We'll do the spreadsheet.
We won't come back
to beta again,
but you need to
see it and hear it.
We come back for
a while, at least.
That exercise, you
will see it's done
assuming there's a certain
level of activity in the plant.
Well, how else are you
going to do it, really?
You could simulate other
levels of activity,
but it's done in a pretty
straightforward, pretty
standard fashion.
If you have the
wind farm and you've
presold the power, then,
again, the revenue--
revenue's fixed.
You don't need to discount
the revenue to allow for risk.
And the cost risks are probably
diversifiable per the example
I said.
And you probably don't
want to treat costs
as a high beta item.
Suppose you don't
know the revenues.
Suppose you're going to
build a gas-fired power plant
and you're going to sell
into the New England
wholesale market.
Oh, well, now your
revenues are definitely
correlated with the
rest of the economy.
Your revenues will have
a significant beta.
Now suppose you're
developing a new widget.
Well, the game changes
now completely, right?
It's a new toy, it's a new video
game, it is whatever it is.
You worry much less-- and we'll
get to this after vacation--
you worry much
less about the beta
on the revenue from
your video game
than on whether you're actually
making something worth selling,
and can you retain the value?
Lots of great ideas do
not enrich their owners.
The person who invented the--
I always pronounce it "kor-ig".
It's pronounced
something differently.
The little thing
that you use to make
bad coffee with the capsules--
made essentially nothing.
So created value,
didn't capture value.
Then all of this
stuff about beta,
and discounting, and so
on, takes a back seat
to strategic
considerations about, well,
how to do I ensure I--
how do I ensure
I sell something?
How do I ensure I capture value?
How do I ensure that my
strategy makes sense?
And finally, suppose you're
a small business with limited
capital market access.
You can't do this borrowing,
and lending, and raising money,
and alternative investments.
Do you know that first acronym?
Has anybody ever heard it?
This used to be the
mantra of the former head
of the Entrepreneurship
Center here.
And it's short for Cash Is More
Important Than Your Mother.
Which, for small businesses,
is often true, right?
We didn't talk about cash
constraints in all this.
We didn't talk about project
size in any of this stuff
I did.
Take positive net present
value projects, it's all swell.
Well, that assumes you can
basically diversify risk.
It assumes you have
access to the market.
It assumes you can
borrow and lend.
It assumes if you have a
bad day, you can get a loan.
It assumes diversifiable zero
beta risks don't matter really.
If you're a small business,
however, a zero beta risk
can kill you, right?
I mean, you're
building this plant.
The construction is uncertain.
You don't know whether you're
going to get it online.
That's uncorrelated with
the rest of the economy.
But if it fails, you're done.
So for small businesses with
limited capital market access,
all of this beta
stuff is lovely.
Large corporations do it,
lots of companies do it,
consultants do it.
It's a lot of fun.
If you're a small
business, however, cash
is more important--
well, not more
important than your mother,
but it's very important.
And worrying about running
out of it will dominate.
And to say to a
small business owner,
well, it's true that you go
broke if this thing fails,
but that's a zero beta risk.
It's not correlated with
the rest of the economy.
You shouldn't treat it as risky.
That's nuts, right?
So the story about beta and
the appropriate measure of risk
for which we have good
theory applies to large--
it applies to ventures
with capital market access,
large or small.
How you think about risk
for a small business
with limited or no
capital market access
really depends on the
exact circumstances
of the small business.
If you've raised $1,000
from venture capital
and you think it's
going to take you
$900 to bring the
thing to market,
you better get it to
market for $900 or you
either go broke or give away
a large part of your ownership
to raise additional money.
So I just want--
I don't want anybody dealing
with a small business
to say, yes, but
what really matters
is diversifiable and
not diversifiable risk.
It does for a big company,
it does for a company
with capital market access.
It's not the dominant
consideration
for a small business.
And it's not the
dominant consideration
in evaluating a project
that really is innovative
because there the real question
is, can I capture value?
And that's a
post-vacation question.
So I'll take questions.
Let me say a little
bit about Wednesday.
Wednesday's a case.
We're going to spend almost
all the time on the case.
I hope you can get the
spreadsheet down from Stellar.
It involves an actual decision--
an engineer, a plant manager,
finds a solution that
will save energy, he thinks.
Well, solution will save
energy, the question
is, is it a good investment?
You will see a spreadsheet that
lays out a net present value
analysis.
I invite you to look
at that spreadsheet,
look closely at the formulas.
Is it right?
Is the analysis right?
Then the question is--
you will also see in the
case a bunch of objections.
I think the spreadsheet
has mistakes.
I think the
spreadsheet fixed shows
it to be a positive net
present value investment.
You will also see in the case--
so it's all the
stuff we all like.
It's an investment
that will save energy,
no animals will be harmed.
They won't be venting
steam into the environment.
They won't have
an icing problem.
Life will be good.
But there are a long
list of objectors--
a long list of
objections, and probably
a long list of objectors, also.
And read that and answer the
question, given those concerns,
what's he do?
Here's a positive
net present value
investment in all probability.
Again, we'll go through
the spreadsheet just
to see how it's done.
It's a positive
net present value
investment that
will save energy,
be good for the environment--
more ducks, whatever-- but
he may not get to do it.
He may not-- and
not because they
don't have any capital in the
bank, any cash in the bank.
He may not get to do it.
So think about
what he should say.
And think about how the
firm from the top management
might want to structure
things so that projects
like that don't get blocked.
So take a look at that.
And let me take questions
for a few minutes.
And again, I'll let you
go-- let you go early.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Related to this,
when people talk
about having compensation
for executives
and people on the board be based
on like a risk-adjusted income?
Would that be based on
nondiversifiable risk as well,
or?
I mean, that's like--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well, they
don't do formal adjustments.
When people talk
about compensation
to try to avoid a focus
on today's share price,
they usually do things like,
OK, we'll compensate you
in stock options.
But you can't cash the
options until five years
after you've left the company.
Things like that to
say the stock price
is $100 today, that's great.
What we care about isn't
what it is tomorrow,
we care about what
it is in five years.
So we want to take away
from you the incentive
to boost profits today if it's
going to hurt profits tomorrow.
So it's not a matter of
risk-adjusted compensation.
It's a matter from the point
of view of the top executives
to give them incentives
not to add to risk, right?
I mean, one of the issues
with all the investment banks
was if there is no downside--
right-- you take
a huge position,
that position comes through,
you make a lot of money,
you get a lot of profits.
That position doesn't come
through, they fire you.
OK, you go to another company.
Well, that's not a great--
that's not a great model.
The idea is we
ought to compensate
you based on performance
over time, not on performance
last week because if the worst
outcome is you lose the company
a billion dollars,
you get fired,
you go to another company--
where you do it again.
So they want to-- you want
to give people incentives
not to put companies at risk.
You want to give
executives incentives
not just to think
about the short term.
It's a difficult matter.
We will talk a little
bit about compensation,
but I will say, one of my
favorite sayings from Jack
Welch when he taught
here was any fool can
manage for the short term only.
And it's also true that any fool
can manage for the long term
only.
The difficulty is balance.
Anything else?
That's the wisdom for today.
Yeah, Julien.
AUDIENCE: If there's
like net market growth,
[INAUDIBLE] is for an entire
market normalized for 1.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
Yeah.
Because remember, in
a well-diversified--
if you are well-diversified,
you own a piece of everything.
That's the best you can do.
You could hold less
of that risky stuff.
But the best you can do in
terms of holding risky stuff
is to hold a little
bit of everything.
And if you do that, then the
risky part of your portfolio
moves up and down
with the market
by definition because
you're holding it,
so you normalize that to 1 and
the riskless part doesn't move,
so that's zero.
You could normalize it
to 16.7 if you wanted to,
but normalizing it to 1
is the simplest thing.
And then intermediate--
then mixtures of the two
will have values
between zero and 1.
Yeah.
I mean, the 1's the
normalization, zero is natural.
Anything else?
Deep philosophical questions?
I will need to talk more
slowly in the future.
And I will do that.
But I'm done.
Thank you.